Canada has a long history of leadership
in the development of artificial
intelligence dating right back to C
far's very first program in the 1980s
Canada's leadership in AI continues
today at the three National AI
institutes created through the pan
Canadian AI strategy six years into the
launch of the strategy we've named over
120 World leading researchers as Canada
seafar AI chairs in turn they train
thousands of students expanding Canada
pool of AI Talent every year as a result
Canada's leading the world for AI
research consistently producing more AI
related research Publications per capita
than any G7 nation and tripling our
research productivity since the start of
the strategy but the impact of the pan
Canadian AI strategy goes Way Beyond
research Excellence the strategy is
delivering significant social and
economic benefits for all of Canada for
example the number number of jobs in AI
has grown significantly more than
140,000 AI professionals were working in
Canada by
2022 this number increased by 29% in a
single year which is remarkable growth
in today's economy and Canada has more
than doubled the number of AI startups
since the launch of the strategy these
are new companies that are
commercializing Innovative AI based
products and services to improve our
lives and economy but it is crucial that
we get the future of AI
and that we deploy and regulate it
responsibly Canada's leadership in
responsible AI development and
regulation will drive Innovation and
economic productivity while at the same
time helping to address some of the most
challenging problems facing Humanity
through these made in Canada
advances all this means that it is truly
the time for Canada to
[Music]
shine